hey always good everybody we are we're
about to answer some fan questions while
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I feel that we will right now we're
actually shooting for one like we're
like planning for one to see if we could
do it but that's one of the goals that's
one of the big goals I feel like it's
super hard with our schedule is super
hard cuz we're never home we're always
doing promo you know don't doing shows
so today women deserve like a lot of
attention so I feel like we can't really
give that much attention to them on the
road you know so we rather just not you
know stay single and thank you focus on
our job yeah in our career
[Music]
oh okay this is Ricardo Ricardo
my name is yeah that's who Ricardo
hablar and this is uh smoke a smoky I
like that name this guy Scarface though
he has like a lot of different features
and say hey for me just like always
I always say maybe a rest man for chart
you know each other you know do like a
picnic day you know I love it okay so
maybe in the Beast
- that's a good place for beach the
first yeah for first date romantic
my pota - I tattooed this ball the able
cuz on on the pool when you I am really
good at scoring the audible the audible
but when it comes to the able I'd always
or either scratch or limit so I just put
it here because I play with this and of
course it but they're like I would like
a - no and I - I come with the cheetah
like the sausage yeah and a wiener I
name is Nana like my ex dog yeah I shoes
unaware medallion you know it's a big
dog like with yellow eyes or blue and
they're super beautiful
inside I put the name has
we'll change it with Richard I will
change it was a deal because he's really
tall and he can't strip and you get
stretch ha ha yeah I need to really flex
flexible let's flex it up our changes
are there too because he saw I would
like to see how how the wind feels and
that you know and there you know that at
that height I would like to go to Hawaii
for once you get Egypt I'm Tyler I Love
New Zealand
go to Japan again man Japan it's a
different world it's like 20 years
events yeah the people you know the
architecture is all they like you know
hey the toilets are the toilets are
crazy man how they're automatic
automatic static yeah the facet is super
fired you normally you would want super
nice
when we are in this we don't see our
family that much and sometimes I miss
her a lot so I think that's the more
hard part of being Tauron and being this
now be with your family so much Japan I
like I really like Japan I really like
Amsterdam - I like sewage to eat and it
was amazing so I Spain Spain worth of
Argentina is amazing Mexico Chile
what are you good yeah hopefully still
doing music traveling the world still
getting to know you things hopefully
doing another interview with puppies
just being successful being happy with
life I always good everybody we are CEO
and thank you so much BuzzFeed
Providence is super finally I'll be back
soon all these puppies are adoptable at
North Shore Animal League America so if
you want a buddy spin by your side
they're here ciao
[Music]